y vamos en directo hasta París con
nuestra periodista Erika olavarría Erika
saludos para usted de París y otras
ciudades se despiertan hoy con las
consecuencias de la novena jornada de
manifestaciones contra la reforma de las
jubilaciones el movimiento parece ganar
fuerzas nuevamente usted qué dice
sí Ángela Sí parece se vuelve más fuerte
y también más joven para darle una
prueba alguna cifras ayer según la cgt
el sindicato más a la izquierda
marcharon solo en París 900.000 personas
y tres coma cinco millones de franceses
en todo el país Obviamente que son mucho
más bajas las cifras que entrega la
policía le digo los participantes son
más jóvenes también pero el ministro del
interior hoy entre una cifras hubo
441 policías y gendarmes heridos
457 personas detenidas en toda Francia y
913 incendios de basuras y de mobiliario
urbano Esa fue la característica sobre
todo de este movimiento ayer muchos
incendios el mismo ministro habló hoy en
la televisión muy duramente contra
quienes manifiestan dice que son jóvenes
a los black block no son dijo son Black
burgueses personas de situación
acomodada que marchan y que están allí
para destruir según él había 1500 de
ellos ayer en la cabecera de la marcha
en París y dice que vienen simplemente a
hacer daño a golpear a un policía dice
él pero tampoco les molestaría verlo
morir muy fuerte las palabras de
gerardman el ministro del interior y una
imagen que ha dado la vuelta en todo el
país la de la puerta de la alcaldía de
burdeos quemada también por los
manifestantes una buena noticia del
movimiento es que al menos en París no
habrá más basura en las calles porque
dos de los tres incineradores han
reabierto sus puertas bueno y Erika una
de las consecuencias además es de todo
lo que nos cuenta es el aplazamiento de
la visita del Rey Carlos III
Sí el Rey Carlos III que debería llegar
este domingo y quedarse hasta el día
miércoles en Francia primera visita un
país europeo Francia estaba muy
orgullosa antes que Alemania sin embargo
ha sido el propio presidente Manuel
macron quien ha llamado al rey y ha
hablado con su gobierno con su país para
decir que mejor no hacer Esta visita
porque él dice no están las condiciones
para recibirlo como corresponde al rey
justamente Esta visita el día martes el
de vía visitar burdeos el rey que es
alguien que es una ecologista No es
cierto convencido quería realizar el
trayecto París burdeo en un tren quería
luego tomar un tranvía en la ciudad de
burdeos la capital del vino y visitar
una viña en esa ciudad de una viña
ecológica y también justamente ir a esta
alcaldía porque va a abrir allí un
consulado sin embargo el gobierno piensa
que las condiciones de seguridad no
están dadas también ese mismo día martes
que es el día en que los sindicatos han
llamado a una nueva huelga general la la
jornada de huelga tenía que tener el rey
una cena en el Palacio de Versalles con
el presidente Manuel macron dice los
analistas no sería bien visto que un rey
estuviera comiendo con el presidente al
que algunos califican el rey republicano
el presidente Manuel macron recordemos
comiendo como Reyes En un momento en que
el país está protestando en las calles y
para decirle un poco que en ese sentido
iba justamente o iban a estar justamente
las críticas a esta cena el comentario
que dejó giant me lanzó en su cuenta
Twitter decía la reunión de reyes en
Versalles dispersada por la censura
popular un término que él ha comenzado a
utilizar dice los ingleses sabían que
dar Maná el ministro del interior sabe
poco de seguridad Así que lo que dicen
desde Inglaterra es que entienden las
razones que entrega a Francia Aunque
obviamente esto simplemente es posponer
la visita para una nueva ocasión quizás
antes del verano